[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas de la situación de la
pandemia kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento los temas
algunos de los que vamos a tratar en
este programa
semana de repunte de contagios y de
fallecidos en américa la región está
experimentando una nueva ola de pandemia
y los récords han llevado a que los
gobiernos tengan que volver a imponer
medidas rigurosas como el confinamiento
estricto o el 'toque de queda' el cierre
de los comercios pero la excepción es
brasil en donde con más de 13 millones
de casos y una nueva variante
descubierta en el estado de minas gerais
el gobierno federal sigue sin tomar en
serio la pandemia incluso han llamado a
es escalar algunas de las medidas a
partir de la próxima semana tenemos
reportes de varios de nuestros
corresponsales en la región para
analizar este tema
y siguen las discrepancias y también la
polémica por la vacuna de astrazéneca
que ha provocado según los estudios o
provoca formación de coágulos en algunas
personas que hayan recibido las primeras
dosis la agencia europea de medicamentos
indicó que se trata de un efecto
secundario y que los beneficios de la
vacuna son superiores algunos países han
tomado medidas preventivas han
suspendido la inoculación de la vacuna o
modificaron los rangos de las edades
para suministrarla dependiendo del caso
y un estudio recientemente publicado por
la revista médica the lancet da cuenta
de la relación que existe entre las
personas que ya han padecido kobe 19 y
los problemas neurológicos o
psicológicos algunos de ellos seis meses
después de haber sido contagiados cuáles
son los síntomas que se debe hacer al
respecto lo veremos en unos minutos aquí
en el programa pues como les decía
estamos en pico de contagio en la región
sobre todo en américa del sur la
situación está muy difícil y vale la
pena comenzar entonces con las cifras
para el cierre de esta semana esto según
el conteo de la universidad johns
hopkins hay más de 134 millones
es 200 mil personas contagiadas en el
mundo entero al muerto 2.9 millones de
personas mientras que 76 millones de
personas han padecido kobe 19 y se han
recuperado al cierre de esta semana han
sido inoculadas ya 410 millones de dosis
de algunas de las vacunas que está
disponible en el mercado
brasil sigue siendo el caso más
complicado por la alta tasa de contagio
según las cifras de este país en brasil
hay 13 millones 200 mil casos
confirmados para el cierre de esta
semana unas 345 mil personas han
fallecido y 11 millones de brasileños se
han recuperado 19.39 millones de dosis
ya han sido inoculadas en ese país
suramericano el senado de brasil
investigará a partir de la próxima
semana de la semana que viene el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro por la
omisión de su gobierno en la gestión de
la pandemia el mandatario por supuesto
criticó este supuesto clima de pánico
que está instalado en la sociedad
brasileña por culpa del cobi 19 veamos
esta cifra bolsonaro será investigado
por su gestión de la crisis sanitaria
así lo determinó el tribunal supremo de
brasil el magistrado luis roberto
barroso del tribunal supremo federal
determinó este jueves que el senado
adopte las medidas necesarias para la
instalación de la comisión de
investigación parlamentaria para
investigar posibles comisiones del
gobierno federal en la batalla contra la
pandemia de kobe 19 algunos senadores
llevaban meses tratando de abrir la
comisión unos intentos frustrados por
representantes aliados de bolsonaro sin
embargo la semana que viene se abrirá la
investigación
bolsonaro ha sido uno de los dirigentes
más escépticos con la gravedad de la
pandemia de kobe 19 desde que lo llamó
una gripe cita al inicio de la crisis
hasta el miércoles que volvió a rechazar
imponer una cuarentena no ha cambiado
mucho sólo recientemente modelo su tono
frente a las restricciones
termina todo menos buscamos un término
medio unas directrices que nos sirvan
para no perder más trabajos y más obras
mientras tanto brasil registró un nuevo
máximo histórico de fallecidos 4 mil 249
víctimas mortales en una sola jornada
el país había superado la barrera de las
4000 muertes por primera vez en toda la
pandemia el martes pasado los hospitales
empiezan a ver cómo escasea el oxígeno y
los medicamentos tres cuartos de los
hospitales privados solo tienen
suministros para una semana más y los
cementerios también están desbordados
solo en sao paulo la mayor ciudad del
país ya se cavan 600 tumbas diarias
día tras día brasil estuvo presentando
récords de contagio y de fallecidos a lo
largo de todas estas semanas ya lo vemos
la situación allí es muy complicada y es
causa de preocupación para la comunidad
internacional valeria saccone la
corresponsal de france 24 está ahora en
la ciudad de sao paulo' precisamente en
una asignación de trabajo que
habitualmente está en río de janeiro
pero nos da más detalles de la situación
general de brasil en el siguiente
reporte
brasil cierra otra semana de récord en
king 2 días para los 4.000 muertos
diarios y en tan sólo 5 días acumula más
de 17 mil muertos y lo peor que la
perspectiva no es buena los
epidemiólogos temen que se puedan
superar los 5.000 muertos diarios en
este momento me encuentro en el
cementerio de vila formosa en la ciudad
de san paulo es el cementerio más grande
de américa latina y de brasil y el
ayuntamiento de san paolo ha tenido que
habilitar entierros nocturnos
ante el aumento espectacular de
fallecimientos diarios un funcionario
nos contaba fuera de cámara que ha
habido noches en que han enterrado a más
de 100 personas la situación está tensa
también a nivel político esta semana un
juez de la corte suprema ha estado al
senado que cree una comisión
parlamentaria de investigación de la
pandemia para apurar la responsabilidad
del gobierno de jair bolsonaro en la
conducción de la pandemia es decir para
decidir y apurar si él se omitió en
gestión que podría haber reducido el
número de muertes la erección de jair
bolsonaro ha sido muy contundente ha
sugerido hacer un impeachment de este
ministro del supremo y de momento no
está clara cuándo va a empezar esta
comisión que podría acabar no se sabe en
qué escenario posiblemente también en un
impeachment
valeria informándonos desde la ciudad
desde el estado de sao paulo en brasil y
en medio de prácticamente una apertura
total y después de haber recuperado una
buena parte de la vida social colombia
se vio forzada a regresar al
confinamiento riguroso particularmente
en las grandes ciudades las cifras
registradas esta semana superaron los
números de hace dos meses el país
contabiliza ya 2.4 millones de casos
confirmados han fallecido 65.000
personas han logrado recuperarse 2.3
millones de personas en ese país
mientras que 2.1 millones de dosis han
sido inoculadas en un plan de vacunación
criticado por su desorganización y por
ser poco equitativo
vamos a conocer más detalles de la
situación en colombia maría clara calle
desde la redacción de france 24 en
bogotá nos tiene más información ahora
maría clara gracias por estar con
nosotros hoy aquí en el programa y
colombia presentó cifras de aumento
considerables a lo largo de esta semana
cifras de contagio particulares en
algunas regiones puntuales cuál es la
situación allí
hola santiago realmente la situación en
algunas partes de colombia es bastante
crítica en este momento el ministerio de
salud dijo que en esta tercera ola el
aumento de los contagios comenzó
precisamente en la costa atlántica donde
está el departamento del atlántico al
que usted se refiere pero la peor crisis
está ocurriendo en antioquia porque en
ese departamento cerca de 13 hospitales
ya se declararon en emergencia en
palabras más simples eso significa que
hay tantos pacientes que ya sus
servicios de hospitalización cuidados
intensivos y de urgencias están
desbordados eso ha generado que por
ejemplo en medellín la capital
antioqueña cerca de 150 personas están
esperando por una cama así y en esa
ciudad la ocupación hospitalaria está al
rojo superando el 98 por ciento la peor
cifra de las ciudades capitales de
colombia incluso uno de los hospitales
envió al personal que trabajaba en
consulta externa o en los quirófanos a
urgencias y a hospitalización porque los
profesionales de la salud ya no dan
abasto
mariah claro con este panorama tan
difícil que usted nos está describiendo
qué medidas ha adoptado el gobierno del
presidente de duke
ante el repunte de contagios que ha
habido después de semana santa el
gobierno nacional impuso toques de queda
nocturnos entre el 5 y el 19 de abril
pero el horario de esa restricción varía
de ciudad en ciudad dependiendo de qué
tan al límite está la capacidad
hospitalaria en cada lugar en algunas
ciudades empieza a las 6 de la noche y
en otras a medianoche además los
gobiernos locales reforzaron con otras
medidas más drásticas
bogotá declaró un confinamiento total
desde la madrugada del sábado 10 de
abril hasta el martes 13 de abril en
medellín también se impuso un
aislamiento obligatorio entre el jueves
8 de abril y el lunes 12 del mismo mes
algo similar decidieron las ciudades de
barranquilla y manizales donde la
ocupación de özil también está al límite
y que hay de la vacunación haciendo un
barrido por los medios colombianos
leíamos muchas quejas por parte de las
autoridades sanitarias regionales
locales que las vacunas nos llegan que
son no es muy equitativo la distribución
de ellas en las diferentes regiones y
que la organización no es óptima que
dicen allí
bueno santiago la verdad es que si en
colombia la situación es crítica en los
hospitales
la vacunación tampoco parece estar muy
bien el ministerio de salud reconoció
que miles de personas que se iban a
vacunar con la segunda dosis y que ya
tenían la cita programada ahora deben
esperar entre 3 y 5 días porque no hay
vacunas suficientes las autoridades
sanitarias explicaron que esto se debe a
que comenzaron a vacunar masivamente a
las personas que se acercaban a los
centros de salud sin importar si tenían
una cita agendada o no y que eso
contribuyó al retraso que está viviendo
el país pero cuando uno analiza las
cifras oficiales ve otras realidades por
ejemplo de las 2,6 millones de personas
aproximadamente que han sido vacunadas
en el país sólo cerca de 600.000 han
recibido la segunda dosis eso demuestra
que colombia priorizó la primera vacuna
y ahora muchos no saben cuándo recibirán
la segunda
incertidumbre entonces para los
colombianos gracias maría clara por este
reporte desde la redacción de france 24
en bogotá en colombia y sin ser la
excepción argentina también tuvo que
instaurar nuevamente restricciones sobre
todo en el área metropolitana de buenos
aires la capital porque los números no
dan tregua más de 24 mil casos en la
jornada de hoy es el cuarto récord
diario consecutivo en ese país
suramericano
las nuevas medidas las dio a conocer el
presidente alberto fernández quien
precisamente esta semana fue
diagnosticado con kobe 19 estas fueron
sus palabras
se prohíbe la circulación entre la 0 y
las 6 de la mañana de cada día según las
jurisdicciones las autoridades podrán
solo ampliar estos horarios en función
de las especificidades de cada lugar
vamos hasta buenos aires allí está
natalia co soy corresponsal de france 24
para profundizar en la situación en
argentina hola natalio como siempre un
gusto tenerlo aquí en kobe 19 la semana
en américa ya oíamos el presidente
fernández hablando de las medidas que
más restricciones van a tener los
argentinos a partir de la fecha
por la aceleración en el ritmo de los
contagios el gobierno nacional dispuso
las restricciones más fuertes desde el
inicio de 2021 comenzaron a regir este
viernes y se extenderán por lo menos
hasta fin de abril es una normativa de
carácter nacional cada jurisdicción
igual la puede ir ajustando según sus
necesidades las restricciones más
fuertes se aplican en las zonas donde
hay mayor riesgo de contagio zonas donde
vive más de la mitad de la población
argentina una de esas restricciones es
la prohibición de circular entre la
medianoche y las 6 de la mañana también
se prohíben reuniones en casas
particulares y encuentros de más de 20
personas en espacios públicos al aire
libre además se suspendieron las
actividades de casinos bingos discotecas
cualquier tipo de salón de fiestas no se
permiten tampoco los viajes grupales de
egresados viajes de estudio ni viajes de
grupos turísticos y específicamente en
el área metropolitana de buenos aires la
de mayor circulación del país el
transporte público quedará restringido
solamente para personas esenciales o
para miembros de la como
educativa estudiantes docentes
trabajadores de escuelas universidades y
jardines de infantes
natalio la vacunación en argentina
avanza lentamente pero constantemente
están llegando lotes de vacuna sputnik
ve desde moscú cómo va entonces el
proceso de vacunación allí porque si se
están disparando los casos de contagio
pensaría uno que la vacunación está más
lenta de lo que pensábamos
uno de los objetivos de estas tres
semanas de mayores restricciones tiene
que ver con detener la velocidad de los
contagios para poder inocular para poder
vacunar a la mayor cantidad de personas
vulnerables
por ejemplo los mayores de 60 años no se
sabe si este objetivo se va a conseguir
están llegando lotes de vacunas de
diferentes proveedores pero hay un
cuello de botella con la distribución y
la inoculación se están inoculando entre
100 y 180 mil personas por día y hay que
ver si eso finalmente resultara
suficiente gracias a natalio por este
reporte actualizarnos de la situación en
argentina natalia coso informándonos
desde la ciudad de buenos aires- y por
espacio de dos días consecutivos chile
ha tenido récords de contagios más de
9.000 casos son cifras que superan
incluso los estimados para las
autoridades sanitarias que ven también
con preocupación la ocupación de las
salas de cuidado intensivo que llega al
75 por ciento recordemos que este país
está bajo confinamiento obligatorio ya
desde hace varios días hay varias
restricciones adicionales
con acción que es ejemplar pero que no
está dando abasto para reversar la
situación del contagio matricial una
desde santiago la capital nos da más
detalles en el siguiente reporte desde
la capital chilena
hola santi cifras preocupantes los que
se informaron en chile este viernes 9
mil 171 nuevos contagios un récord
histórico que supera incluso las peores
previsiones del gobierno y también las
cifras más altas registradas en la
primera ola en la que no se alcanzaron
los 7.000 contagiados a diario el
ministro de salud de enrique parís hace
un punto de empresa excepcional para
llamar al país a la unidad y también
recordar a los chilenos en la necesidad
de cuidarse y de cuidar a los demás en
este momento crítico que atravesamos
mientras que el colegio médico señala
que estas cifras ponen en jaque a un
sistema hospitalario que se encuentra
prácticamente colapsado ya en un cien
por cien y muestra su preocupación por
lo que pueda ocurrir cuando estos altos
números de contagios se traduzcan en un
15 por ciento de ingresos hospitalarios
y un 3 por ciento en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos además desde el
colegio médico se llama a extremar las
cuarentenas a conceder más ayudas
sociales para que la gente no tenga que
salir a la calle
esto cuando 16 de los 19 millones de
chilenos ya están bajo 40 en absoluta
pero se sigue viendo bastante movilidad
en las calles y también llaman a mejorar
la trazabilidad del talón de aquiles del
sistema sanitario chileno en la lucha
contra la pandemia
patricia luna desde la capital chilena
ya lo ven ustedes la situación es
delicada por lo menos en estos cuatro
países que hemos analizado a lo largo
del programa seguimos con más cifras
ante este repunte de contagios porque
vale la pena dar un vistazo también a la
vacunación que no avanza a la velocidad
que los países necesitan ya lo estamos
viendo en argentina y en chile también
muchas de las farmacéuticas han tenido
problemas para cumplir con sus entregas
no solamente en américa latina' en
europa también ya vimos complicaciones
en eeuu es el país que están liderando
la vacunación tanto en el continente
como a nivel mundial 112 millones de
dosis ya han sido inoculadas méxico ya
superó los 8.9 millones de dosis costa
rica llega a las 292 mil 398 dosis
inoculadas vámonos a américa del sur
chile lleva más de 7 puntos 12 y 17
puntos millones de dosis inoculadas
uruguay ya llega a las 798 mil dosis
inoculadas este fue uno de los últimos
países que comenzó a vacunar y venezuela
ronda ya las 98 mil dosis aplicada
en este país suramericano
y lo avanzábamos también en el sumario
de temas de este programa sigue la
polémica en torno al uso de la vacuna de
astrazéneca porque supuestamente
propicia la formación de coágulos o
trombos como efectos secundarios así lo
ha confirmado la agencia europea de
medicamentos ema precisamente esta
agencia también reconoció que si bien
hay una conexión con 169 casos
reportados que desarrollaron coágulos
los gobiernos han tenido que tomar
medidas desde suspender el uso hasta
restringir las dependiendo de la edad de
los pacientes veamos
aunque en casos muy aislados los trombos
podrían ser un efecto secundario
producido por la vacuna de astrazéneca
así lo determinó la agencia europea del
medicamento sin embargo ésta sigue
resaltando que los efectos positivos de
este fármaco son mayores a las amenazas
que presenta
son efectos secundarios raros muy raros
greater than the risk el riesgo de
mortalidad ligada al coi 19 es
considerablemente más importante que el
ligado a los efectos secundarios más
esto es importante difundir el mensaje
de que las vacunas ayudarán en la lucha
contra el hobbit y que debemos continuar
utilizándola sentinel travestis vaccines
hasta el momento la agencia de
medicamentos ha examinado 86 casos de
trombosis atípicas de las cuales 18
mortales surgidas en un total de 25
millones de ciudadanos vacunados con
este fármaco en la unión europea y el
reino unido el regulador británico de
medicamentos también resaltó los
beneficios de la vacuna
sin embargo aconsejó no aplicarla a
menores de 30 años te pagan subvención
risks isbert y el equilibrio de
beneficios y riesgos es muy favorable
para las personas mayores pero es
ligeramente menos favorable para los
jóvenes aconsejamos tener en cuenta esta
evolución de los datos para decidir la
manera en la que la vacuna será
utilizada
y otros países europeos como bélgica
países bajos o italia han anunciado que
destinarán el uso de esta vacuna a
personas mayores de 60 años por su parte
la farmacéutica sueco británica asegura
estar trabajando en entender la causa de
los casos de trombos y las muertes
relacionadas a las campañas de
vacunación y miren ustedes haití es uno
de los cuatro países del mundo que no ha
comenzado a vacunar contra el kobe 19
porque no ha podido adquirir o recibir
algún lote de algún tipo de vacuna a
pesar de este panorama el gobierno en
puerto príncipe- declinó las vacunas del
laboratorio astrazéneca que le
ofrecieron la organización mundial de la
salud a través del mecanismo de
solidaridad
kóvacs ya sabemos los efectos
secundarios que puede tener esa vacuna
el organismo le advirtió a haití que los
plazos comienzan a acabarse
sin rastro de la vacuna contra el cob y
19 en haití un año después del inicio de
la pandemia la nación de más de 11
millones de habitantes no ha recibido ni
una sola inyección a 756 mil dosis de
astrazéneca asignadas a través del
mecanismo de naciones unidas- kóvacs y
cuya entrega está prevista para antes de
mayo podrían retrasarse puesto que las
autoridades no realizaron correctamente
los procedimientos cuando tienen un goya
la cab
wendy tuqui legación y conozco mucha
gente que pregunta cuándo estarán
disponibles las vacunas porque necesitan
vacunarse lo que significa que hay gente
que quiere vacunarse y hay gente que
está obligada a vacunarse por su medio
de vida o su profesión visión el que
jacmel la empobrecida nación caribeña
sumida en varias crisis de seguridad
política y social que desde inicio de
año ha llevado a miles a salir a
protestar a las calles carece de la
infraestructura necesaria para
garantizar el almacenamiento adecuado
del suero según las autoridades
si bien las mascarillas son obligatorias
en las plazas de mercado apenas son
visibles
se supone que el gobierno nos va a dar
más mascarillas para el coronavirus pero
no nos dan las mascarillas y no sabemos
dónde ir a comprarlas las venden a un
precio más alto del que podemos pagar
somos pobres no podemos pagarlas por eso
no usamos mascarillas y es que muchos
haitianos no creen en el coronavirus un
desafío que podría poner en jaque su
frágil sistema de salud y la percepción
de la población que no cree en la
existencia del cobi 19 la reticencia de
una gran parte de la población a ir a
hacerse las pruebas incluso cuando
tienen algunos síntomas que parecen de
gripe mucha de la gente podría pensar
que el kobe no existe
esa es una de las grandes luchas la gran
negación de la existencia de la
enfermedad
la inestabilidad hace que muchos se
pregunten cómo se van a administrar las
vacunas en una nación donde la población
se preocupa más por la violencia la
pobreza que por el virus ecuador celebra
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales un momento político muy
importante que presenta retos debido a
la pandemia en pleno rebrote vamos a
conversar entonces con gustavo ortega en
quitó para conocer cómo están preparando
allí estos comicios gustavo gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en kobe 19 la semana en
américa y ante el repunte de los casos y
también con las elecciones a la vuelta
de la esquina qué medidas se han tomado
allí las autoridades para que los
comicios se desarrollen normalmente
en el ecuador llega a la segunda vuelta
electoral para elegir al décimo segundo
inquilino y para ello de gobierno desde
la vuelta a la democracia en este país
en medio de restricciones sanitarias a
causa de la pandemia
a pesar que concluye el estado de sesión
este 9 de abril no concluyen las medidas
de protección sanitaria y restricciones
para ejercer el voto este domingo es por
ello que los ecuatorianos deberán
cumplir con nuevas reglas en medio de la
saturación hospitalaria que algunos
hospitales e inclusive atienden a 145
por ciento con pacientes en el suelo los
pacientes llegan con cuadros más
extremos y requieren mayor tiempo de
hospitalización y para estas votaciones
de consejo nacional electoral imponen
nuevas reglas la conformación de los
centros electorales se realizará
ampliando la distancia social y los
votantes deberán ubicarse más lejos a
dos metros de los miembros de mesa para
mostrar si su cédula se evitarán las
concentraciones y grandes filas como
sucedió en la primera vuelta electoral y
se priorizará el flujo de personas e
ingreso y salidas separadas de los
electores en los centros de votación y
los militares y policías fueron
capacitados para evitar así las
aglomeraciones habrá libre circulación
vehicular durante el fin de semana pero
se retomarán las restricciones
desde el 12 de abril para realmente
algunas autoridades municipales buscan
que se extienda el estado de sección
durante 15 días más luego de las
elecciones inclusive se deberá aportar
su propio bolígrafo y ya no se exhorta a
votar por el terminal seguro sino a
votar de manera fluida para evitar las
concentraciones gustavo jogo remezón
político está en ecuador porque llegó un
nuevo ministro de salud el presidente lo
nombró de quién se trata a quien asume
esta cartera en pleno rebrote de kobe 19
con las elecciones a la vuelta de la
esquina y el país sin dar síntomas de
mejorar en cuanto a la pandemia
bueno menos de dos meses que incluye el
gobierno del presidente de ningún moreno
en su administración concluye con los
peores niveles de aceptación de un
gobierno con más del 90 por ciento de
rechazo en este país la inestabilidad y
la rotación de ministros hace una
constante durante los cuatro años de
gobierno ante el fracaso y la
inexistencia del plan de vacunación en
medio de la pandemia solo en el caso de
la salud durante esta semana y casual el
sexto ministro del ramo al gobierno de
lenin moreno de los cuales cinco
anteriores renunciaron a su cargo a
causa del mal manejo durante la
aplicación de las vacunas y la pandemia
los privilegios en la administración de
las doce y supuestas diferencias entre
funcionarios aglomeraciones de adultos
mayores en las calles listas vip y
vacunados un gol destinados a los
funcionarios gobiernos o amigos cercanos
de éstos ha sido la constante en la
aplicación de las vacunas en este país
eso sin tomar en cuenta que durante la
administración de lenin moreno pasaron
cuatro vicepresidentes siete ministros
de ambientes 7 secretaria de
comunicación 5 ministros de viviendas 5
ministros de gobierno y 5 ministros de
transporte
gustavo al igual que en otros países de
la región la vacunación es la gran
apuesta de las autoridades sanitarias
allí cómo está avanzando entonces la
vacunación en ecuador
bueno comer se ubica entre los últimos
15 países de américa latina en la
cantidad de dosis aplicadas por
habitante hasta el pasado 6 de abril en
el país andino se habían aplicado un
poco más de 350.000 dosis de las cuales
el 68 por ciento corresponde a primeras
dosis eso se traduce en dos dosis por
cada 100 personas y lo ubica en el
puesto 36 de 49 países del continente
americano según datos de la organización
panamericana de la salud desde el 20 de
enero de 2021 han llegado 780 mil
vacunas y se han administrado del 46 por
ciento según cifras oficiales inclusive
por lo cual se mantiene una velocidad de
vacunación muy baja en el país y se hace
casi inalcanzable tener una vacuna pero
el gobierno no ha logrado crear un plan
de vacunación efectivo ni un manejo de
la pandemia adecuado al que se agrega el
incremento de los casos muy acelerado
que genera una desconfianza en los
ciudadanos
gustavo pues importante del caso de
ecuador por las elecciones para este fin
de semana gracias por este reporte desde
la ciudad de quito cambiamos de tema a
un estudio publicado en la revista
especializada the lancet schalke a turín
que una de cada tres personas que se
contagiaron con kobe 19 presenta
problemas neurológicos o psiquiátricos
en los seis meses siguientes al contagio
entre las secuelas incluyen ansiedad
accidentes cerebrovasculares e incluso
insomnio los expertos aseguran que estos
síntomas pueden volverse crónicos
muchas de las secuelas de el coronavirus
en la salud mental son a largo plazo
la investigación publicada por la
revista the lancet psiquiatra asegura
que una de cada tres personas que
tuvieron joven 19 presenta problemas
neurológicos o psiquiátricos en los seis
meses posteriores a la infección por
coronavirus entre estas secuelas que
ocurrieron entre 1 y 180 días después
del contagio se identificaron las
siguientes hemorragia intracraneal
accidente cerebrovascular parkinson
síndrome de guillan barré trastornos
nerviosos encefalitis demencia
trastornos psicóticos del estado de
ánimo por uso de sustancias ansiedad
insomnio entre otros el análisis fue
hecho por un equipo de la universidad de
oxford que examinó el historial de 236
mil 379 pacientes mayores de 10 años
registrados en una base de datos de eeuu
escogieron personas que se habían
contagiado de coronavirus después del 20
de enero de 2020 según uno de los
especialistas del estudio las secuelas
post kobe pueden quedarse en el cuerpo
por un largo tiempo desgraciadamente
muchos problemas identificados en este
estudio tiene
tendencia a hacerse crónicos o
recurrentes por lo que podemos anticipar
que el impacto el coi 19 podría perdurar
durante muchos años pero los
investigadores subrayan que la
incidencia de trastornos psiquiátricos y
neurológicos en pacientes de kobe 19 no
se deben necesariamente a la acción
directa del virus en el cerebro sino que
puede derivarse de los efectos
personales y sociales de padecer la
enfermedad o del impacto de sus síntomas
nos vamos ahora hasta eeuu el presidente
yo baiden hizo importantes anuncios para
agilizar el plan de vacunación allí
también hay un repunte en cuanto a las
cifras pero ahora la mirada está
enfocada en millones de dosis que han
comenzado a sobrar porque muchos
ciudadanos no quieren vacunarse qué
hacer con estas dosis se lo vamos a
consultar entonces a mamá en sala
nuestra corresponsal en la ciudad de
nueva york mamen
comencemos primero por los anuncios que
hizo el presidente bailen ahora todos
los adultos se pueden vacunar que más ha
dicho el mandatario
si aquí en eeuu el ritmo de vacunación
es cada vez mejor para que solo es una
idea se están administrando una media de
3 millones de dosis diarias hay ya más
de 112 millones de vacunas puestas en
una población la estadounidense en la
que pese un 20 por ciento está
completamente inmunizado y más de un 33
por ciento ha recibido al menos una de
las dosis las cifras son muy positivas y
el presidente joe biden se une a este
positivismo y adelanta la fecha en la
que cualquier estadounidense adulto
podrá acceder a una vacuna al 19 de
abril es decir dos semanas antes de la
fecha que se había previsto
eso ya está ocurriendo en algunos
estados como por ejemplo aquí en nueva
york donde desde esta misma semana
cualquier persona mayor de 16 años puede
vacunarse eso si los jóvenes que tengan
16 o 17 años sólo podrán hacerlo con la
vacuna de facer que es de momento la
única que se ha autorizado para ésta
amén hay buen ritmo en cuanto a la
vacunación pero también los contagios y
las víctimas mortales siguen aumentando
en toda la unión americana también hay
una nueva variante que fue descubierta
en una región del medio oeste de la
unión americana que dicen los
conocedores que dicen los científicos
allí en eeuu
si la cifra de nuevos contagios todavía
están lejos de esos terribles picos que
vimos hace unos meses pero
desgraciadamente todavía no está
controlada hay un promedio de 65 mil
nuevos casos diarios en todo el país y
los contagios están aumentando en el
medio oeste de eeuu algo que preocupa
mucho a los expertos sobre todo porque
para que os hagáis una idea son 5
estados en este país los que concentran
el 43% de los nuevos casos de kobe 19
son nueva york nueva yersey pensilvania
michigan y florida aquí es donde se
concentra el 22% de la población y donde
se está recogiendo la mayoría de esos
nuevos casos preocupa mucho también a
los expertos las nuevas variantes del
virus sobre todo la procedente del reino
unido que ya es la predominante en este
país está completamente extendida por
los 50 estados
preocupa porque es mucho más contagiosa
y además dicen los expertos que si no
conseguimos controlarla podría
encontrarnos ante una nueva ola de
contagios como la que está
experimentando por ejemplo europa me
llama mucho la atención que eeuu bueno
ya sabemos produce vacunas ha comprado
lotes inmensos de cantidades de dosis
para inocular a sus habitantes pero
muchos de ellos no se quieren vacunar
otros simplemente no han podido acceder
a las vacunas por diferentes motivos y
están sobrando las dosis están sobrando
las vacunas que van a hacer con ellas
si eeuu fue rápido a la hora de negociar
y adquirir vacunas para su población
desde el principio dijo que antes del
verano eeuu recibiría 400 millones de
vacunas en una población de sólo 390
millones y donde se espera vacunar a
cerca de 300 millones entonces la
pregunta ahora es qué va a pasar con
estas vacunas que no se administren se
van a devolver a los fabricantes se van
a conservar se van a repartir a otros
países que sí que las necesiten de
momento desde el gobierno son muy cautos
porque todavía falta mucha información
aseguran que todavía no sabemos si
después de que una persona haya sido
completamente inmunizada va a necesitar
otra dosis o si en algún momento por
ejemplo se van a poder vacunar los niños
son los que ahora nos está contemplando
en esta primera campaña de vacunación
entonces de momento prefieren actuar con
cautela lo que sí sabemos es que se van
a enviar cerca de 4000 dosis a mexico y
a canadá pero de momento no se ha dado
ninguna respuesta pública
al resto de países que están solicitando
vacunas a eeuu en caso de que sea
posible distribuir las que les sobren
también pues ya veremos a dónde van a
parar estas dosis de vacunas que tiene
eeuu gracias por estar portes desde la
ciudad de nueva york es todo por el
momento aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa nos volvemos a encontrar la
próxima semana por favor sigan
cuidándose el korona vido seguimos en
emergencia en toda la región de américa
latina siga con nuestra programación
hasta pronto
[Música]